I'm here at Google Cloud next 2023 with
Benazir a machine learning specialist at
Google here to tell us what we can
actually do in real life with large
language models
for bringing to the table is a lot of
functionality to enable these large
language models in user in Enterprise
use cases the most common use cases that
we are seeing is one chat bots so how
can customers interact with businesses
in natural language right
second how can customers interact with
all the data the documents and data that
enterprises have how can we search that
data in a more efficient way yeah and
third these language models are able to
code so you know you can very easily
generate code and increase developer
productivity
to learn more check out vertex Ai and
duet AI at Google Cloud